- Here's the biggest problem,
bullshit entrepreneurs cry
about the way they want it to be
instead of reacting to
the way it actually is.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Man] If somebody wanted to,--
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Man] They live in
Silicon Valley, that's cool.
Then you get a
$150,000 license a year--
- [Gary] Don't
get it twisted, man.
Stop your hate real quick.
Most people that get
money from Silicon Valley
don't come from Silicon Valley.
So stop it right there
but I'm not
letting you just cliche it,
'cause that's bullshit.
It's just not true.
- [Man] Okay, an
entrepreneur like me,
what if I wanted
to study cannabis?
- [Gary] Then move to
fuckin' Denver, bitch.
(audience laughter)
Fuck Houston.
- [Man] No, but why do
I have to move to Denver?
- [Gary] Because
that's the current law.
(audience laughter)
- [Man] You're right,
you're right.
- [Gary] Why do I hate
Texas with all my heart?
Yeah, I'll tell you
exactly right to your face.
I hate Texas,
listen, I hate Houston
more than you fuckin'
hate the system right now
because I built a wine
business where I shipped wine
and this fuckin' bullshit
ass state took spec's money,
the politicians and
blocked only one store
from shipping to Texas, me,
'cause I was at
the top of the heap.
I was doing
$4 million in sales here.
Saving all Texas people
money 'cause I was creating
competition and the
wholesalers, three of them,
paid your fucking
bullshit ass Houston politicians
to block me from shipping here
and one day I got
a letter and said
you can't ship here anymore.
So what am I supposed to do?
I can open a store in
fucking Texas and throw down
or I can adjust.
That's what you have to do.
Nobody gives a fuck
about your feelings, bro.
(audience laughter)
No, but for real.
And the reason I'm
coming at you like this is
I'm pumped for you.
You're a kid.
Don't cry about,
here's the biggest problem.
Bullshit entrepreneurs cry about
the way they want it to be
instead of reacting to
the way it actually is.
(audience applause)
So you need to
eliminate rich kids 'cause
I was born with dick.
I lived in a studio apartment
with eight family members
on the size of this stage and
split toilet paper. Okay?
So there's no excuse.
Most people that are
born with wealth, bro,
they lose 'cause they're soft.
So if you're so
angry put it to good energy
and got move to Denver
or enjoy 19 to 22, chill,
then move to Denver or
wait for the laws to change.
You can't cry about how it is.
That's just never ever,
ever, ever the right move.
Sunday afternoon,
just landed from Vancouver.
Did like 757 emails.
Super clean. Felt great.
I was excited to go home and
watch a little basketball
and just get ready for the week.
Realized I have to go to the
office and film some content
for some clients.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is a special edition of
The #AskGaryVee Show for--
Michigan won.
They're in the Sweet 16.
Ross is happy
and gonna be away on
family vacation next week
so we've got an episode tomorrow
and then we'll go dark.
Decided, you know,
maybe I'll sneak an iPhone one
here and there or maybe
with Jordan working out.
We'll probably sneak some in
but nonetheless, we'll see.
Yeah.
- [Jose] Okay.
- Like what are you gonna
talk about it and
then fucking sit on assets
when they go down 30 to 50%?
- [Jose] No, I pretty
much have to pretty much
sell everything off.
- That's how you do it.
- [Jose] Okay.
- I sold my Twitter
stock when I thought it wasn't
gonna be as
valuable and I was right.
That was a good idea.
- [Jose] Yeah.
("Waste No Time" by Sonik)